did you really stop a rape in 2006 yes
how did you do it
uh-huh fisticuffs is it so do you want
to do on the pole story well yeah and
that's a pretty interesting thing I mean
we'd never heard that story before so I
um it's ridiculous I am like a ex-heroin
addict and at 2006 I was on a lot of
heroin and I was living in my apartment
ah this like shitbox on Allen Street and
Broome and I was watching TV with my
then girlfriend at the time and I uh I
was like in just pajama bottoms it was
like April and it was raining a little
bit and I hear this scream for help
right right hear this commotion
downstairs and I I ran down and I was
literally at the landing of the stairs
there's like two double doors you know
or there's double doors in New York and
in the sort of hallway vestibule between
the doors was my I could see my upstairs
neighbor pinned down on the ground
face-up and this guy was like trying to
rape her basically and so I ran back
upstairs just to the landing and I went
inside it told my girlfriend I was like
listen lock yourself in here call the
police
like tell the cops to come right now
like on heroin right and so I run
downstairs and I open the door
and she's on the ground the guy has left
and I grab a metal pipe because it's a
[ __ ] building in Chinatown so there's
just [ __ ] everywhere right so I got this
metal pipe I run out the landing and
there's nobody on the street I looked
north and I look south and there's this
guy on Allen Street and he's running
south and I'm like oh this is the
[ __ ] right so I'm there I'm like
a hundred and fifteen pounds soaking wet
like y'all you know in pajama bottoms
and I'm like I [ __ ] like you
trying to rape my neighbor and he turns
around he he Minds having like a gun in
his sweatshirt pocket and he goes I'm
the police and I'm like [ __ ] you and I
hit him with his metal bar right and he
fights me and he takes off running and I
go after him he bolts into some
apartment like a housing complex like
just I think like you know near Allen
and grand and he slams my arm in the
door yeah and I smash the glass with
this pipe because I'm trying to get a
hold of him and I slipped
it's wet and so I end up like sir
raiding my entire chest in broken glass
so I basically look like Iggy Pop right
now and uh the cops show up and they
think I'm the rapist because I'm like a
junkie like blood right and I'm like nah
it's the other guy and so what happened
was they picked him up I think a couple
hours later and then I had to go like
picking out of a lineup and then testify
against him in court I don't know what I
don't know what ended up happening but
that's the story so when when you hit
the pipe where'd you hit him like in the
shoulder I know you know it wasn't like
I'm not I'm not some super skilled right
Steven Seagal no I mean I'm also like
you know like was a 115-pound junkie
with a pipe actually gonna do to you by
the way how slow is he that the guy on
heroin Cory yeah yeah yeah so that's
that's the story that's pretty ballsy to
chase him down Superbowl